y diversidad cultural encuentro de dos
mundos pluriculturalidad o resistencia
indígena estas son algunas de las
expresiones que han ganado fuerza para
renombrar la conmemoración del 12 de
octubre en américa latina' desde inicios
del siglo 21 casi todos los países de la
región han optado por resignificar esta
fecha para reivindicar a los pueblos
indígenas y la pluralidad cultural entre
los pueblos originarios en la fecha
recuerda la resistencia más de 500 años
después de la colonización que para
ellos significó violencia esclavitud
saqueo de recursos y tierras y
devastación de sus culturas para
nosotros es la continuidad de la vida en
la resistencia
ante la imposición del pensamiento y la
filosofía
patriarcal en la acumulación del dinero
con los recursos que son nuestros
hemos vivido
tres siglos con el imperio católico que
nos impuso sus normas leyes sus
costumbres en méjico la figura de
cristóbal colón ha sido puesta en
entredicho al punto que se retiró una
estatua emplazada en ciudad de méxico
las estatuas de colom empezaron a ser
cuestionadas precisamente por la misma
razón por la que habían sido construidas
porque eran símbolos de la dominación
occidental porque eran símbolos de la
dominación religiosa católica porque
eran símbolos de una idea pues un poco
glacial izada de la historia en que se
decía que américa debía ser gobernada
por los hombres blancos
en la actualidad a su lucha por el
reconocimiento histórico y el derecho
sobre las tierras ancestrales los
pueblos indígenas suman consignas como
la lucha contra la crisis climática y la
protección de la naturaleza frente al
avance de actividades económicas que
amenazan la biodiversidad